[Music]
so all five of these friends were alive
and completely the same in 1897 I get
that vampires are immortal and you could
even convince me that Frank and mummy
dearest are the same but do wolf persons
and invisibles not age either tickets
ladies character doesn't look at
obviously disguised characters for us
sensible comedic effect cliche what is
this another scooby-doo sequel not only
is this German child speaking English
but he's speaking modern English slang
in 1897 I am now pretty sure young
Friedrich von Kaka Schmidt here can
travel through time except if he goes
forward he has to live as an old man and
if he goes backwards he ends up as a
child so whenever he tries to tell
anyone there they think he's a child
playing make-believe or senile old man
my point is I'm already so bored with
this movie that I'm writing other movies
in my head and this can't be a good son
yes one of the Van Helsing's
Expos introduction oh yeah remember when
the famous vampire hunter of Anthony
hull skins used the laser gun to subdue
Dracula always an underrated part of
that legendary story I know you haven't
even gotten into the movie yet but
seriously why isn't he firing this gun
he's got him dead to rights he survives
this and this and this and this and this
and this and this and this and this sure
it's a cartoon but just remember that
death or danger has exactly zero stakes
for anyone in this universe considering
this movie attended the wily coyote
school of surviving things and sunny she
doesn't cry she bites the thing I love
most about the Hotel Transylvania is the
adorably casual cannibalism natus looks
less like a married a hundred and twenty
six year old vampire and then a
millennial that used a gift card at the
lazy Raven that her cousin gave her last
year the day I married Johnny was the
best day of my life
Oh awesome Johnny's back from the last
two movies anyone care pink Johnny we're
not allowed to bring our dogs I mean our
pets everywhere this seems like a very
simple and important rule that should
land these two assholes in giant trouble
you can even find someone to sing with
on your phone now setting easy tinder
humor aside why would it be Holloman
that brought it up isn't he the one
person without a profile pic I'm looking
for a date skip I'm lonely I understand
you want Bologna when we're doing this
part of a film to fill some time before
we leave for a boat boss good okay just
put the entire trailer in there oh you
know what that's why you're the boss
boat's not into senticles
wait if dating apps in the monster
universe exist there would totally be a
vampire specific one it took like three
seconds after Grindr was released for
wine Christian farmers with neck tattoos
meetup.com to star and a vampire woman
wouldn't even have to be that specific
Matt found forget the fact that Drakon
black here didn't even swipe that
picture at all what kind of dating app
immediately video calls a person after
it finds a match for you eavesdropping
barging in and blocking or the old
boner killer trifecta yeah absolutely
right
I think the only specific direction Adam
Sandler was given was to use the most
annoying register in his vocal range are
you a monster this is clearly a setup
for them to get on the boat right if so
how did they know Mabus was thinking
about a vacation right the second and
that this TV is on and how did they even
take the TV over in the first place I
can deal with all kinds of fantastical
creatures in this movie but this is some
bull
as crazy as this looks still not
anywhere near is back but insane as
gremlins to 20 because they're monsters
and all monsters are assholes I guess is
it funny also why do they have to take a
monster specific airplane at all they
were riding perfectly well on the train
a few centuries ago before Van Hot
Pockets showed up and why doesn't
Dracula have his own boat specifically
for these purposes
[Music]
god bless Adam Sandler for doing the
work of bringing attention to the
genital trauma humor this country needs
in these trying times I mean since every
day in this country feels like a new
kick in the balls why shouldn't our
movies reflect it so authentically
poured the hours in the closet sized
room with you and uncle Bernie arguing
who was more interactive Cleopatra or
Nefertiti I'll admit that 40 hours is a
long time but it's not like they were
talking about the structural integrity
of a steel reinforced casket man they're
discussing intimate details about two of
the most attractive women in the history
of history
that's hardly a snooze fest the series
is clearly an exercise and stretching
the very limits of Adam Sandler's
tolerability to a film audience getting
there then increasing it by 3,000
percent
cuz up with this giant puppy why is it
here and why do we care about it wait
there was a shirt I had to catch
in addition to two other movies I'm
forced to sit through I can't believe
I'm saying this but that puppy sure most
if not all these assholes are immortal
but incredibly human Johnny survives
this who made you such an amazing doctor
it's like Adam Sandler watch Steve
Carell in the first despicable me and
said hey I can easily do a borderline
offensive Eastern European accent for a
similarly unlikable and ghoulish
character for three stupid movies to
came out Steve this is an absurdly large
ship right so why are there so few
people booked on it there were only a
couple of dozen on the plane and we
haven't been shown anyone else boarding
yeah what's up with that other than a
cheap excuse to show a more tinkles
footage won't even qualifies as a pet in
this universe they literally have a blob
of slime that travels with them it's
that not hard to clean up after
darling what's the movie that we take
the kids to that we don't have to
explain awkward things afterwards all
right what kinds of things I mean Hotel
Transylvania three is playing oh that's
perfect they're certain to be no casual
bestie ality that will require some sort
of discussion hi mom what in the van
helsing even is this movie
seaweed rewrap Wow it sounds like
everything we can do at our hotel oh so
he's surly again now tell you what I'm
just gonna add 20 cents for each time
Drax a grumpy dickhead then is talked
into having fun only to appear in the
very next scene is a grumpy dickhead
that's nice thank fire bad remember
despite his asshole demeanour Drac would
be excellent at cinema since what am I
saying because of his asshole demeanor
Drac would be perfect its innocence
oh no he's having a heart attack or he's
recycling the exact thing he did in his
SNL audition either way it's bad to be
scary
hang on is this literally an allegory
for the gay cruise experience is that
okay to do have they checked with the
proper authorities
I'm just saying someone's gonna be
offended really fish cravats is the best
you could come up with I mean a crow
bass is right there or three-ring circus
circuit if Elaine don't try to go
portmanteau to toe with me mister no no
not okay
not okay somehow Adam Sandler's initial
script reactions made it into the final
film hey well you might want to change
your front cape then I went to the moped
store salesman's like what up what's
your budget I genuinely have no clue why
these fish are doing a spoken word
version of a Macklemore song but it
feels funny and subversive and since
there's nothing else like that in the
movie I'm gonna angrily send this
mackerel more a moment instead of
registering my appreciation for its
inclusion so blob no heart here is
asexual and procreates by getting sick
and vomiting up its children does that
mean that tongues or birth control is
epic an aphrodisiac our blob frat
parties full of new kids by the end of
the night I've so many questions how are
these obviously feral puppies not
considered pets goddamnit that no pet
sign at the beginning was the stupidest
part of a very stupid movie and five
cents damage I'm still not sure I
understand you take my kids all day
purpose dear gluten-free God and
unleavened heaven another side story
this movie doesn't have a plot so much
as it has a series of unrelated and
astonishingly unfunny sketches it's like
SNL had a baby with a sentient piece of
raw sewage whatever we want
whatever we want whatever we want
this goes on for some time also didn't
they have at least some assistance at
the Hotel Transylvania I know this
boring parents finally get a break from
the kids Fantasy plays to a certain part
of the audience but like everything in
this movie is dialed up to 11 to boil
all the humor out of it so right
great-grandfather villain poses as love
interest of the protagonist before
immediately showing her long lineage of
evil cliche and so I began to search
France this is a character reading 4x
position during narration in a flashback
this is like the turducken of sin
moments this movie is a cheap maximum
sin Duncan and Leslie I searched and I
did this instead of finding virtually
any other way to kill this one
individual also I mean seriously even if
one man alone can't take drag out there
are so many other things to try trying
to burn the castle down recruit an army
to seize it recruit a relocation service
to move the entire castle to the equator
this is the most convoluted and
expensive plan ever conceived even
dumber than operation faithful patriot a
full 90 seconds of an alternative Bruno
Mars video for 24-karat magic that's
almost as stupid as the original video
movie is now taking a few minutes for an
attempted murder dance montage I swear
the actual script of this thing must
have been like five pages it doesn't
make any sense
you can't sing twice well I mean it's
all dependent on medication you take and
the length of the refractory period and
of course the willingness of your
partner so I wouldn't say you can't also
jokes aside what the hell is with this
rule Dracula is essentially immortal as
long as he follows certain rules about
crosses in the Sun to the universe
seriously set up a general rule that
even if you live forever you can only be
content with one person
I mean Ariana Grande's already broken
this rule several times and she's only
25 why is the water up to dracs waist
but below Mavis when we know for a fact
that Drac is quite a bit taller than
Mavis out of the water
aside from the fact that this Bigfoot
joke is the same Bigfoot joke as the
last five times we've seen it in this
movie alone this movie make up its mind
on his size somehow he was able to sit
inside a plane that would now easily be
crushed by his step
why does so many of the monsters need a
scuba tank like the vampires are already
dead they don't need to breathe same
goes for the mummy right really the only
one that needs this Johnny and movie
said pal to that character thirty
minutes ago huh I guess convoluted
stupid expensive unnecessary plans
really do run in the van helsing family
thinking it was too obvious to jump the
shark though
you literally decided to hypnotize it
and ride it around the ocean is that
Johnny a human swimming over an active
volcano that's currently erupting god
damn this movie stupid so the legs are
what caught your suspicion and not the
obvious mechanical submarine the fact
that this movie stupidly wastes talents
like keegan-michael key makes me mad
enough to mummify my monitor so I don't
have to watch anymore this bolt
complementor your neck looks delicious
yeah about that none of the three full
vampires and one half empire have eaten
on this entire trip it's not like there
are many humans to pick from - so Drac
is gonna need to make a move regardless
unless he wants to start snacking on
pork and Johnny oh yeah remember that
case story that I'm sure will have a
huge impact on the overall narrative
yeah me neither
hope you people that paid the extra in
the theater for the 3d images of drool
being throwing your face we're extremely
satisfied har-har this menus full of so
many bad puns and cliches it just got
greenlit as a family comedy on Netflix
also there's a lot of bull on that menu
but still no blood despite knowing this
is exactly where vampires go on vacation
have you a beverage to quench me of my
parchment damn even the troupe of cameos
are over stuffed in this movie edit
komali that's so that's so racist
I guess the movies been holding that
fart joke in for almost 10 minutes which
has got to be some kind of record
my wife died how old was your daughter
she was just an infant
man we're getting some Highlander style
both on the ages here the rack is
obviously super old but he looks
middle-aged and you can assume he was
turned into a vampire around that age
but Mavis is 126 and she looks like a
con Selena Gomez right but she had an
infancy my point is like every other
vampire movie before you just give us
some goddamn rules oh that's cute honey
well it's been fun last one out turn out
the lights
we're done here I'm not sure which is
the endless side plants in this flaming
pile of a movie is the most pointless
but loop on Duggars ditching their pups
is the leader in the clubhouse for sure
despite everyone being in the proper
place to eavesdrop all over the ship
this loud argument is totally private in
fact
when mr. pink and superstar finally do
show up they haven't heard discount mr.
ruby boogie too
yep the apex of the culture of humanity
throughout all of history is visualized
as a king las vegas casino I honestly
think the cast has lost track here and
think they're making grownups 3 which
takes place entirely in Monte Carlo I
can't lie to my own daughter anymore
she's the most important person in the
world to me and I'm reciting my
character motivation so that they will
be clear to the audience who may have
fallen asleep 30 minutes ago Bob why
would he be with Bob Bob's a great guy
isn't me here is Johnny getting more and
more stupid in this series whatever zing
Mavis saw in him in the first place has
apparently been smoked out of him and
security at Atlantis the most secretive
location in the entire world by the way
is way looser than I thought it would be
honest I can't tell if this moustache
gang is actually kind of funny or if
it's just the thinnest kid at phat game
either way it's sad when this is the
closest you get to a laugh and a movie
that's supposed to be checking my notes
yep a comedy holy jesus is chasing is
taking so long I think it's about to
take the record from bullet Yeomans
well for one monsters are apparently
allowed to party in a location that's
been hidden from everyone in history
with no supervision I'm here to get that
yeah it's a family heirloom yeah it was
lost it at sea Kathryn Hahn usually has
a very distinct voice but you could have
easily convinced me that this was
Jennifer Aniston this is like Kathryn
Hahn literally doing a Jennifer Aniston
impression and it's distracting us from
the scene with their black and white
outfits and setting off booby traps only
makes me long for a really well done Spy
vs spy movie or the sweet release of
death I'd honestly take either at this
point man good thing none of those
arrows or made out of wood aren't there
several sticking into where Drax heart
would be even if they came through his
back he's pretty dead right now
right Drac decides to run Erica out of
here instead of simply flying since we
got to stretch this for as
long as it'll go I could never be with a
monster oh sweet if we're already at the
protagonist fight right before the end
of the movie cliche and that means it's
almost done right right
never lies really is this another solid
attribute of a Xing or like the
previously mentioned only zinging wants
is one that might change is there a Xing
king who decides on these things at
Monster weddings do they have Xing
bearers to some mayor just survive on a
singing prayer can you have a zing fling
is a divorce considered a zing animus
I'm just saying this whole Xing thing is
plot contrived nonsense and well
deserving of at least 30 Zynga
ding-dings
I know I made an Okie boogie crack
before but I mean between the Halloween
esteem the cranky old genius with a god
complex that's stuck in a mobility
device the shelter daughter figure
looking for more to her existence the
implementation of a whole new world and
the singing sack of bugs out in the
water we've got an honest-to-god
Nightmare Before Christmas ripoff I'm
just gonna go ahead and send this for
being way too many minutes of a rave
that even I'd be too old for let alone
monsters who's been around for hundreds
of years what's most important to
understand is that what I'd like to
understand is where the spotlight is
coming from that is following him during
his blue light special because it's
never even addressed of course part of
me is glad considering they probably
would have just panned up to see some
sort of monster eating baked beans whose
farts have a blue glow so silver linings
I guess you can't deny Xing monster
human unicorn god damn it that's the
second overt allusion to bestie allottee
in this movie and I'm freaked out that
whomever wrote it is getting into the
minds of the current generation
[Music]
so it was everyone okay with dying this
took several seconds to set up which is
a ton of time for drag or Mavis to run
up there and snatch the music they all
just too curious to see how this bold
ending turns out if you got Megadeth up
there you could have had an entire
symphony so let's talk about Van
Helsing's plan shall we somehow convince
all the monsters to go on a cruise on a
ship his daughter captain's to get them
out to the lost city of Atlantis and
even though he already has the location
of this secret weapon and knows all
about it he waits until they're all
there to try and retrieve and since he
had a synth ready he must have known
that inside was a dubstep song that had
survived the destruction of the city and
any kind of water damage so that he
could play it with all the monsters
gathered at a rave he also somehow knew
that this would initiate the crack to
attack and destroy the monsters who
again somehow all decided on their own
to take this vacation do I have that
right do I then release the crack sins
[Music]
to be fair this is also my immediate and
visceral reaction to hearing dubstep rap
but many of you can fly and you can take
other goddamnit this is pointless I've
written so many crack and related
sincere that it's getting redundant in
my head so just trust me when I say
horrible but then a Pirates of the
Caribbean sequel and metal cover kind of
like Kanye and Kim get ready for a DJ
battle you just carry all that stuff
around with you yakety Drax has a point
but would still suck at cinemasins
because that's how much I hate this
movie no credit given suck banging we're
gonna use good music to defeat his evil
music and you know this works because
just forget it can someone just say they
all live crappy ever after so we can
call it a day oh dude you don't even
know how bad it is to watch it I like
this magical DJ scene when I saw it
years ago and Scott Pilgrim vs. the
world so I was about an extra 40 cents
for how long boring and unnecessary this
is a old mother this Cape is showing
zero doctor strange tendencies this
entire movie but it's now dancing the
Macarena on its own because that's the
song that defeated the musically
hypnotized singing Kraken to save the
monsters does someone bother to say this
stuff out loud at any point in the
writers room
plage product placement meets slime
product placement slime blush
movie and hopefully franchise ends on
one of the least important plot points
in the history of the King franchise
although look I might be talked into
seeing a spinoff the features that jazz
fish group but said too much
and if I see van helsing could there be
a female gremlin lipstick boobies bitch
you have he and little gremlin vajayjay
I love it so much that it's not only in
the movie but it's definitely in the
movie I'm gonna go check on you know loo
I'll be right back I have waited so long
to meet you I'm gonna roll you into a
little ball shove you up my vagina you
live there I replaced my feelings with
[Music]
release the Kraken